so since everyone who for being here my
name is Hal and I work for the Apache MX
net science team at Amazon AI which is
part of a database so today I'm gonna
introduce a new package that we're
developing we are under development to
accelerate your large-scale machine
learning applications it's called an MP
on mix net so let's first talk about
what is mix net and so it is an open
source deep learning framework under
Apache and our new package is a new
numpy compatible interface that will
allow you to retain your familiar numpy
functions api's I mean while also
allowing you leveraging the parallelism
of modern computer hardware and also it
is providing you with extra deep
learning features so what exactly does
that bring so one thing is that we are
definitely maintaining the
interoperability with official numpy and
meanwhile we're also providing parallel
acceleration for all the existing numpy
operators and we have provided extra
operators and functions for your deep
learning related work clothes and
another thing we're introducing is the
automatic automatic differentiation
functionality so let's just take a look
at the actual season actually running in
the jupiter notebook so the first
feature I'm going to talk about is
interoperability with official numpy so
that means you can use it with any
existing functions you know implemented
it was official numpy let's take a look
at this example which is just won't yes
so here we are importing the numpy and
the numpy extension module from mix net
and we are also important the original
numpy as the official numpy and then
we're creating two arrays here that is
the that is our number
the array so if you print the type of
them out you can see this is of the
mixed net number in the array so now we
are trying to add them up using an
official non-biased function and you can
see that works so it will give you back
it will just dispatch to our
implementation of the class function and
will give you a result this C and this
type of C is still makes net and umpire
in the array so you can also so this is
au funk you can also call another
function some to some maybe along the
zeros axis and then we get another
tensor that is see some which is also
still a mixed net number in the array so
this means if you have if you already
have some helper functions of your own
defined in official numpy as long as you
if you feed the a mixed net numpy in the
array to it it will just function as
normal as before so the next feature I'm
going to talk about is that we provide a
parallel acceleration for the existing
operators so if you take a look at this
example so this is a very simple piece
of code we're trying to create two very
large tensors and matrices and we're
trying to perform a dot product on them
right so this is pretty simple so if we
just do it with the original official
numpy it just look like this so we
measure the time we can see this so we
do the operation as normal but we also
measure the time it takes to for it to
finish so we can see this consumes about
point zero seven two seconds and so this
is actually done on a pretty good server
machine with 32 CPUs so if you're
already spending that kind of money
you would you would want something more
right so if we just switch to our
library by just re really important from
mix net and we are still just calling it
in the same way and we measure the time
we can see we get a 0.06 seconds on CPU
so that's about 1.2 1.3 times speed-up
was just a change of the library on
exactly the same machine was exactly the
same hardware so now we can take it to
another level that we want to run on
GPUs so to run on GPU is really simple
so if you just use the as in context you
can just put it on any GPU so you can
index your DP like if you have multiple
GPUs you can so they have indices of 0
to I minus 1 and then you can just put
it on any GPU so it as long as you put
your operands on a GPU then there any
then you just call the function as usual
and operation will be automatically
dispatched to GPU computation so here we
can see this only costs the exactly same
operation cost us zero point zero zero
three four seconds on GPU so this is
about a 30 to 40 times speed up just by
moving your data and it's just like a
two line change so we can see the how
powerful the modern part of modern
hardware is and I definitely want to
leverage the parallelism of them so
another feature I'm introducing a
[Music]
so non-pilot currently does not walk on
GPU naturally but we can definitely
compare with Cooper if you want the data
on it but I actually don't have that
data in hand yes so and so yeah the next
feature I'm going to talk about is the
MPX deep-learning
operators so in deep learning there's a
lot of new operators created to serve
different purposes so for example let's
take a look at this convolution operator
which is applied on maybe an image or
you can also apply on like 1d data like
audio signals and also maybe 3d data
like like video snippets so let's take a
look at how this works so you have so in
convolution we have a kernel or we also
call maybe filter but that is sliding on
the input image so for every position it
arrives it's at the weights within the
oil filter is multiplied element wise
was the input data and then summed up to
generate a new value so we can see this
one is multiplied with this one and this
one is what if I was this zero so it's a
zero so this one is one if I was this
guy and this is my pair was this guy so
in the end the sum is 4 so we also so
this is usually used as a feature
extraction method in deep learning that
is automatically automatically learning
some patterns or those kind of things so
another operator I want to talk about is
like pudding so it's like where it's
like a convolution but without the
kernel you directly extract so you have
a window sliding on an input image and
then you directly derive some value just
based on the values that you are
covering so maybe you take the maximum
out of them or you take the average out
of them so it so it's called a max
pooling and average pudding respectively
so also there's a category called
activation functions which looks like
this so we have a wide range of them but
here I'm just showcasing like two of the
so why is the sigmoid function which is
widely using neuro networks and also the
regularize linear unit so you can easily
implement them in official numpy but
we're just providing some short hands in
the MPX namespace for you so that you
don't have to write them on your own
so by planning them we can see those so
those are the they add non-linearity to
your model so that they can do more
things right
so one last feature I want to talk about
is the automatic differentiation
functionality so what it does is
actually when you're performing some
forward computation on your model it
tracks all the operators that you are
using and also and then when you want to
do a backward propagation where that is
calculating a gradient of your model it
back tracks your previous forward
computation and it will help you with
all the gradients and so then in this
way you can you can avoid defining your
own gradient functions that will remind
you of your calculus courses back in
your college so so this will you know
give you a lot of convenience so
especially when you have a really
complex model that deriving its gradient
step by step is a really pain in the
back right so let's take a look at one
example of this so we want to so there's
an operation and deep learning called
patch normalization it is performed as
the as this graph shows so it has in
total like nine to ten steps so and we
we need the gradient of this from time
to time so let's first take a look at
what is what this guy is doing right so
we have some input data and we also have
a parameter called gamma and we also
have a parameter called beta which is
the bias gamma is like the multiplier
and then for any input data we are
normalizing on the patch on a patch
dimension of it right and then we are
calculating till this point we're having
the
variance and at this point we're having
something like the standard deviation
and then we then we divide one by it and
then we multiply it with our original
like the difference between every data
point and the and the average along the
batch dimension and we want to multiply
it with this gamma parameter and we want
to add it with this bias and then we get
the output so it's in total like ten
steps so to implement it an official
numpy is like this so notice one thing
is that every operator here I'm every
function using here or from the official
numpy library okay and then so in total
there's like nine steps right and in the
end you also want to cache all the
intermediate values if you're writing it
in official numpy because you will need
it when you compute the gradient so
let's take a look at how we're doing on
it so we have some we random we randomly
generate some data and we call a
function on it and this just runs
smoothly so as I said the benefit of
having the interoperability is that if
you have some helper function that is
defining official numpy you can still
use it without any problem so now let's
see how we do it in your official numpy
that is we have we just cause all those
tensors to numpy erase and we just call
the same function right so we get two
different versions of the output now we
want to see if we're doing it correctly
all right so we always think the
official numpy is doing doing perfect
right so we are now checking against all
the data it's not just about the final
output it's also about we check every
intermediate steps so that we are not
just like say getting the final answer
luckily just by chance right so we can
see the output of this code snippet is
at every output matches for both between
hi and official numpy so actually this
is not quite painful yet right so
because we're not doing the gradient
thing so let's revisit this graph and
see what do we need to do for the
backward propagation you need to derive
the gradient for this guy and this guy
both right and then you will have to
propagate all those gradients all the
way back through the upper branch which
has like two sub branches right so this
is and also every single step in this
every single backward step in this could
actually remind you of your calculus
class okay so so to do it
an official non-pilots let's compare so
it's nice steps in total that you have
to go back right so you have to define
such a function and you have to go
through all those steps so still this is
defining a facial umpire so you'll have
to get your cached values back and then
you also have to go through all those
steps and in the in the end you are
returning the three gradients that you
are looking for which is on the input
data on a gamma operator on a betta
operator so this goes like this right so
you just randomly initialize some
gradient on on the on the output and
then you try to propagate it back right
so that is how we're testing and then we
can see that this just functions and it
gives out some values for the for the
gradient for the gamma for query of the
data and gamma and beta right so now
let's see how do we do it with automatic
automatic differentiation you only have
to do like several like you don't have
to write an extra backward function
anymore right what you do is just like
for everything that you want to compute
your gradient on you you attach the
buffers for holding their gradient of
values and then you wrap your forward
computation with this record
scope so that it can track keep track of
all the operations you are doing in the
forward pass right and then see we don't
even need the cash values anymore
because we are not computing out of them
right we just let the underlying library
to it so when you have the buffer ready
when you have wrapped your forward
function with your record scope you can
after the computation where you want the
quick way what gradients you just
directly call backward on your output
buffer and then providing it with the
the gradient the D out that you want to
use and by this time every single inputs
a gradient are in their thought grant
buffers respectively so so actually so
this will this will compute all the
gradients which was respect to the the
tensor you are calling a backward so it
will compute all for all its variables
so in this case the DNP out is derived
by what the PI is is obtained through
the computation on data gamma and beta
so it's back propagating into all of
them so let's see do they match right so
we're we're just checking against
checking between the great the grad
buffers and the official num highest
result so you can see that all of those
gradients still match so we are getting
the right answer but with just way less
hassle in the middle with automatic
differentiation so now let's think of
how we can build a model that works with
this new package so we're gonna operate
on this data set which some of you might
know this is called a fashion amnesty
that is it contains 28 by 28 images of
fashion goods and we want to categorize
them into their corresponding categories
alright so how are we gonna do it maybe
we can build a neural network to do it
so let's prepare
our environment first so we'll be
importing the MP and MPX package from
mixed net and here we're setting we're
calling this function to set the mix net
to its numpy compatible mode because we
also have some backward compatibility
things to address right so and another
thing is that we are using the automatic
differentiation so that's why we're
importing the autograph
right the autograph module and we will
be borrowing the data loader from our
glory library but will be I think we'll
be working on - I'm getting rid of it
getting rid of the data logger to make
the data more numpy native so let's
first prepare the data loader you know
we when we want to operate on some data
we always want to prepare it first right
so we set the batch size to be 256 and
we are defining some transformations
here which is you know you are
transferring the image to the individual
images to a part of a tensor and here we
are using a parallel data loader here
the number of workers is set to 4 so
that means if your it will use 4 CPUs
whereas in parallel to load the data
that which will accelerate the process
so in the end we get to iterators over
the data set why is for the training set
when it's for the test set so this is
not very interesting but so now let's
move on to defining our models so we
want to do a two layer multi-layer
perceptron model with so 28 by 28 is
just 784 pixels and we want to
categorize them into ten different
categories and we also we design a
network to have 256 hidden nodes so we
we initialize all the parameters here
right we have we have the weight for the
first 40 connected layer and the bias
for the for the first 40 connecting
layer and also the comma beta because we
are using the bash norm function here
and - and also we have the second layers
weight and second layers bias and and to
easily manage them we want to cut them
into this collection so that
you know we can access them easier when
we were training the model so for each
of the parameters we definitely want to
compute the gradients on them right so
for each so we're just iterating through
this collection and allocate the
corresponding memory space for their
gradients so then we move on to define
our model right so this is so the first
function here is a regularized linear
that I talked about previously we have
that available in the npx namespace too
well here we're just showcasing like we
can also do it in the official an umpire
this is just one line code right so
another thing is that we are defining a
simpler version of our passional here so
you can see we're not collecting the
cached values in the middle which is
directing you know returning output
because we're using the automatic
differentiation module and we don't need
them anymore
so here we have the network's but we
have the network defined here so the
input is of batch size times 28 by 28
and then we want to reshape them into
batch size by 784 which is the shape of
our input and then we we dot the input
with the first layers weight and we add
the first layers bias to it and then we
pass this through the steward activation
function and then we're also applying a
bash norm to the output of the hidden
layer and then for finally we just
multiply the normed output with the
second layers weight and add the second
layers bias to it so in the end we get a
matrix of shape batch size times 10
which is for each of the sample it gives
its output value for each of the ten
categories we want to classify them into
and to keep track of how our model is
doing we're just using the softmax
cross-entropy
loss function so firstly softmax is a
function that will 4/4
for like four four for example for the
ten output categories is computing the
probability that each of those could be
so the output was sum up to one for each
sample and so for each of the sample we
want to what we want to do is that for
the for the ground shoes of say it's
category five right we then it's then
the saris then the then the y value will
just be five right and then we then we
want to take the probability from the
softmax function and apply a logarithm
to it and we some odd with some of the
negative values of all of those log
values up to get other to get the total
loss of the predictions and also we want
to define an optimizer function which
here we're just using stochastic
gradient descent where is weight decay
so for each of the parameters for when
we want to update them we multiply their
gradient with the learning rate and
divided by the total batch size and we
also add this weight decay punishment to
it so that we limit the magnitude of all
the parameters so another thing to
evaluate our model is that we want to
see how accurate it is that is how how
how much chance
how much probability it has to give the
correct prediction right compared to the
ground truth of that picture so to
calculate the accuracy so the Y hat
value is our predicted value which is
batch size by 10 and the Y is just a
single label that may be ranging from 0
to 9 so for each so we are just our
models prediction is just the maximum
value out of the 10 categories so we
want to get the index of it and we
compare to the label if it's correct
then we just
returned just one right otherwise it's
zero so we sum all those up and we get
the total number of correct predictions
so this is perfect this is refactor here
and we also want to accumulate on the
total number of examples not just the
correct one also the wrong ways right
so dividing those two numbers we get the
percentage of giving correct predictions
out of our model so it's all those set
up we can now begin training our models
so we are training for like tangy pokes
and the learning rate is 0.5 so for each
of the epoch you can see we are wrapping
our forward computation with this record
scope and the network was just defined
right and then we are also passing it
through the last function so we want to
minimize the loss so that's why we are
computing the gradient of other inputs
and the parameters with respect to the
loss function right so we're calling the
backward function on the loss so and so
by this point right but after this
function call every the gradient of
every single parameter is ready in their
corresponding dot grad buffer right so
we did so now we can call the optimize a
function to optimize our model and for
each of the and also for each of the
iteration we are also keeping track of
how we're doing on that batch on you
know so then we are accumulating our
loss and our accuracy and also the total
number of samples
so for each epoch after each epoch of
training we want we also want to
evaluate our model on a test dataset
that is the data that it has not seen it
so that we know how how well it's going
to be doing when it's facing when it's
put in the world right so we are
printing we're printing out those values
so if we visualize the whole training
loop it looks like this so we can see we
are the the loss function is
you know actively decreasing and we are
staying at a where we're increasing the
training accuracy and the test accuracy
from time to time and also in the end we
can see they don't differ much so that
mean that that means were good with
we're not having overfitting on the on
the training dataset so if we also want
to visualize the predictions of our
model that is we are actually predicting
on actual data so because so the upper
label is the actual label the lower
label is the predicted label so we can
see for those four things they're pretty
obvious so there the model is doing
great so this one might be a bit
confusing so the model is a bit tricked
by this but overall I can you know we
our model is doing pretty good I would
say so if we just go back to the slides
after showing all the working samples to
you I will also like to introduce you to
a PPP because when we are training model
we're just not you know doing it for
hobby for fun right so we also want to
put it into production so we have so
mixed that actually has an easier pass
for deployment that is we actually
supports in total of eight language
bindings except Python we also have
julia we have Clojure we have our we
have c++ we have pro we have java we
have Scala so it integrates well with
all those languages and you know
especially a lot of them are used in the
production systems these days right so
another so we are we also have a big
ecosystem so one thing in the whole
ecosystem is that we have a deep
learning textbook that is written based
on this new package and it comes with
you know working code snippets
mathematical formulas and also we
provide a discussion forum if you have
any questions and also here if you have
feedbacks so it's Chinese version has
already being released last year it was
a number one bestseller on China's
biggest retailer site and another thing
is that it has been adopted by twenty
more than 25 universities globally for
their deep learning machine learning
courses so this book is accessible for
free at d2l a id2 area and then we also
have in addition to the textbook we also
have several toolkits available for you
to use was ready to use tools we have
glue on CV which is a computer vision to
care : op he is the national language
processing toolkit
Quan tears is a time series predict
modeling toolkit and these days quaff
neural networks is also on the edge of
the trend so we also have a deep graph
library that is deep learning on graphs
so something we want to work on in the
future is that we definitely want to
extend our operator function coverage
and we also want to further improve our
performance of the library and one way
to do it is that we have cooperation
with Apache TVM project which is a deep
learning compiler that will generate
tunable computation kernels and also we
want to enable deployment on various
hardware not just you know big servers
it includes CPU GPU and also maybe
arm-based devices and also via our
cooperation with Apache TV so that's off
of my talk and also I provided and
ipython notebook containing all the code
available at this link you can actually
just find my profile and it's like the
top pinned repo there anyone got any
questions
oh yeah sure so firstly this interface
is okay so the question is what does
this have what advantage does this
library has over other deep learning
frameworks right so I think some of them
I've mentioned I think we've got a
pretty incorporated integrated ecosystem
and also as I said we have language
bindings for you too for your easier for
easier deployment paths and also this
very library is fully compatible with
numpy that you don't have to change any
code that is you don't have to learn a
whole new interface you know as we all
know tensorflow is has a very deep
learning curve to master and and you
know it's also true for other frameworks
that you have to learn new functions you
have to get yourself familiar with all
the details of that framework to fully
master it all right so I think that's
the advantage of this very package that
is you don't actually have a lot of
learning code learning curve for you you
can just directly transition from your
numpy code to this new level no actually
it's an Apache project so it's fully
open source it's not hosted within
Amazon Amazon is just one of the key
contributors we also have contributors
from the community and it was also we
have contributors from Intel and media
who are working on integrating their how
you know they're optimized libraries
that to accelerate all the workloads
right so and also maybe they work on
some features especially for CPU and GPU
things yeah
is the main difference for the reason
that 20% of this operation yeah so I'm
gonna repeat the question so what is the
reason that it delivers about 20 to 30
percent just out of package on some of
the basic operations so one thing is
that for a lot of the operations we are
we are integrating with the hardware
vendors libraries so that that may not
be adopted by official numpy another
thing is that for a lot of the operators
we are providing we actually we are
providing parallel acceleration we
paralyze anything we can paralyze on any
operators but for now I'm it may not be
the case so I think that is also another
reason yeah that's pretty
I think that's pretty much it so again
the question is or the not so does the
novelty lies in the fact that this
package provides functionalities that
will provide will allow developers to
write the same algorithm with less
hassle yes
so I mean accelerating something does
not just mean the performance it's also
that we want to cut time on the on the
on the time for you to writing write
code to debug your code to look up the
API s so in I think in this way we are
we are doing the job to firstly let you
retain your original functions
you know interfaces api's and also we
are also accelerating during the runtime
right it's not just the develop time
it's also the wrong time right so it's
it's boss I would say
the question I asked was
different function in this case are you
simply yes yeah so as my one of my
examples show as long as you put your
tensors onto GPU they just automatically
runs on GPU with the same function yeah
I'm gonna go back to that specific
example here that is moment so running
this on GPU right if you compare it with
the code like on CPU it's just you cast
those in on two GPUs you just put them
on the GPU and all this function car is
not change so if you have some functions
well defined as I said in some helper
functions you can just call it as normal
but just put your data on the on the GPU
so it's always maybe a two or three nice
change depending on how many data you
have
don't have too many changes yeah on GP
yes that's a good question we have not
we we have not oh sorry
so how does this sofa question was how
does the performance compared to how
does this packages perform as compared
to number so my answer is that's a good
question I think will be that number is
not a target that we are benchmarking
against which I think we are actively
benchmarking against coupe I and and
Jack's but I don't have the data on hand
right now but if you're interested I'll
reach out to you - yeah after we've done
benchmark so the question was does this
have any specific GPU requirements so
yes this runs on NVIDIA GPU only but we
actually runs with very old versions of
those even you have SM 30 architecture
we we will run on it and also on the
NVIDIA edge devices such as justin tx2
something like that
so so the question was is there any
plans to extend the support to other
branded GPUs so for that I think there
are two paths going forward one thing is
that I think there are some AMD guys in
our community talking about adding the
support for AMD GPUs and also as I said
when through our integration with Apache
TDM we can extend support you know
operator support to not just AMD GPUs
but also a wide range of devices such as
edge devices add GPUs those kind of
things any more questions so we're good
yeah thanks everyone
[Applause]